in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week
[Music]
today the show is about my most favorite
topic it's about food can food make us
sick that's what I'm going to talk about
with dr. Andrea storm here in Berlin at
the Red Cross clinics in Berlin West and
welcome to in good shape dr. Andrea
stone is an expert on nutritional
medicine gastroenterologist and head of
the clinic for internal medicine you are
what you eat however not everything what
we're eating is good for us dr. stone
what exactly is celiac disease so select
disease is disease where the surface of
the small bowel is disappearing patients
are not able to absorb nutrients for
example iron ore for legassik or albumin
so the body is starving
when you perform gastroscopy what would
you see would give you a hint that the
patient suffers from and select disease
if you go with the endoscope it's a
small bowel which is depicted here you
can see very nicely the increased
surface of the small bowel here so the
scalloping of the Thals
it's a typical sign for celiac disease
we go in we take biopsies and the
pathologist will tell us that is a
decreased surface and this is the first
hint of celiac disease when where does
it come from
it's an immunological disease so the
background is genetic so somewhere on
your chromosomes is determined that you
will develop surge of disease later in
your life say anything which can trigger
it like the use of alcohol for instance
unfortunately we do not know any
triggering factors it would be nice to
know it because we know that their
families was a high prevalence of celiac
disease if your father or siblings have
already selected zis it would be nice
for you to prevent it however there is
no medication or there is no action
which can prevent the disease and what
are the usual symptoms how would I know
that I suffer from celiac disease it
depends a little bit on the age of
diagnosis for for infants usually it's a
retardation of the gross
it's bloating if the kids are not
developing nicely
so they're going to the pediatrician and
then some blood tests will give you the
results with all there are grown-up
peoples usually it's anemia you feel
fatigued you feel tired you know you
your face gets pale you go to a doctor
and he will diagnose anemia if it
doesn't accept then you know you have
celiac disease and other any risk groups
who more of would develop celiac disease
yes we know it's a disease more of the
white people and more of females but
however there many countries in the
world the probably the diagnosis is not
really made due to inability of
endoscopy and blood tests but until now
we know it's more into Western countries
and that's a patient's number vary from
country to country so the Western
countries are more affected than say the
Asian countries there's a high incidence
of celiac disease in India too and also
it's coming up in China we do not have
good numbers for Africa for example and
and how do you treat severe disease the
most important treatment is waster of
gluten to avoid it in your daily food
because this triggers inflammation it's
like an allergy you have to avoid
allergic medication which is in that
case gluten so after three to six months
you GI tract is normal again but it's
difficult to avoid gluten in your daily
life and and can you cure the disease
it's a genetic disease and there's no
cure available really for genetic
diseases maybe in twenty or thirty years
we do not know that but you can decrease
the symptoms of the disease and you can
live a normal life with a normal life
expectancy but it's normal it's it's
important that you're not starving and
that your iron and folic acid and so on
and so forth is restored to normal
and it's this disease dangerous yes it
is first of all if you do not have
enough nutrient you can stop people can
starve to death if the diagnosis is not
set on the other side you know if you
prevent gluten you know usually of a
normal life expectancy however some
patients might develop a lymphoma due to
continuous inflammation we have to
diagnose it early and have to treat with
chemotherapy dr. Sturman is that right
to say that gluten intolerance can lead
to select disease know that to complete
different disease entities the Celica
Z's is an allergic disease the gluten
sensitivity is called non celiac disease
sensitivity so it's an intolerance of
gluten nothing to do with an immunologic
disease so is it dose dependent then
indeed allergic diseases are independent
from the amount of antigen in most cases
but if you have just a sensitivity it
might be the case that you are
tolerating low doses of gluten or of
antigen but high doses may cause
abdominal pain bleeding or fatigue which
is an often a symptom of gluten
intolerance when I look through the
internet or through all the social
networks I think that this is more like
a trend right now we see with the gluten
sensitivity so do you think it's a trend
on the one hand yes you know a lot of
people now have to change sensitivity
but on the other side we are changing
our microflora don't forget that our
genetics are determined for 10,000 years
but the microphone changes last 10 to 20
years rapidly depending on food from
Chinese restaurant Indian restaurant
from our travelling which has increased
in the last decades so a micro for our
changes and so our tolerance to what
food is changing to so if I would think
that I'm gluten sensitive what should I
do
so what you should do go to a doctor and
check if you have celiac disease if you
do not have celiac disease but can be
determined by blood or by endoscopy try
to avoid it try to decrease the we
stopped looted from your food they are
signs here in Germany or other countries
here it's like a green sign we can show
or we can see that there's no gluten or
very very low doses of protein and try
to eat it it's more expensive and it's
inconvenient because you cannot go just
easily to restaurants and eat whatever
you want but if you want to avoid it
that's the best way to do so is that the
right choice to skip gluten altogether
no that's not the case gluten is not
healthy or it's not dangerous it's just
a part of wheat so if you want to avoid
it that's fine but eating gluten is
healthy too and you cannot save any
calories and don't get
Obie's no that would be nice that would
be nice
we got a viewer question from russia
maria smirnova wants to know if she can
just cook her food in a certain way to
get rid of mutant you cannot destroy
gluten by cooking so you have to buy
nutrition's which are gluten-free you
cannot get it out of your food if I
tolerate gluten as a kid can I develop
the gluten sensitivity over the years
yes you might you know that elderly
people have a different Michel Fortin
young people and so your tolerance to
different nutrient nutrients or sugars
is changing yes you can develop it later
in life
and if I'm gluten sensitive and my life
partner is not is it dangerous for me to
use the same knife for instance of the
same plate you have to distinguish
between between sensitivity and celiac
disease if you have gluten sensitivity
and eat gluten nothing happens with your
body it's just like bloating and in
comfortness but there is no damage to
your body so it doesn't matter when your
girlfriend or boyfriend cuts a knife
that's different to Sherlock disease
which is an allergic disease and you
should avoid you must avoid eaten in
this case thanks so much for inviting me
today thank you
you
[Music]